today we're going to be drawing Disney
characters from memory from my brain I
hope I do okay I depends which movies
they are cuz some of them I don't know
oh boy
are you serious hurry now Maui character
I know that guy I haven't seen mallanna
oh just draw join the rock Johnson I
mean I I know kind of what this what
this character who looks like he's like
big and yeah anyway
again just drawing the rock Johnson
shirtless and you're there no I think
he's got like an oval face Yeah right I
think he's like no does he have a nose I
think he has a big nose I remember she
has like these really distinct horns I
know she has like a very narrow lovely
triangle thing yes like a very angular
angular this is bad I know she's green
she looks like Angelina Jolie oh god I
look like him at all okay okay so I
think he's got like the top hat right
yeah he's got he's definitely got a top
hat okay but it's like a small top hat
and then I think his body he's got a
little bean body and a vest I think and
probably like a bow tie he's like a
little dapper Dapper dude but he's like
wider right how do you square he's kind
of a square yes because I'm doing him as
it like a series of spheres
uh-oh his head's got to be huge Disney
cartoons of those big old heads
I think he's gonna just give a nose I
feel like he has a nose like a big nose
like in my mind he's looking like Joe
Camel like he's got Joe camels by camel
nose kind of um I love Maleficent
because her whole reason for being evil
is that she didn't get invited to a
birthday party I love her
he has very beautiful hair right it's
like long like long and flowy looks like
Dwayne the rock Johnson's hair right he
has lots of cool tattoos with like his
like life on them or something like
every time you did something cool do the
tattoos like move yes they do
I do know that wait what props does he
have
he has a like a hook right yeah oh yeah
I'm like oh I don't know her actually I
had to do I'm drawing him and he's not
looking like what's in my head
he's got like a little best right like a
1920s suit
okay and he's got gloves so they gave
him gloves because Felix the Cat had
black hands and whenever his hand went
over his body it would disappear
so they started giving cartoon
characters white gloves the other came I
don't think so
oh I'm gonna draw on the cane cuz it
just looked so it looks right for me
he's built right yeah he's not like he's
not like rock built he's not no he's
like even filter than rock but I don't
think that's the rocks fault
oh no he's animated listen it's never
the rocks fall I'm gonna give him
antenna I know he doesn't have one but
it's gonna make my picture look more
like I wanted to look okay I think I
just drew an alien oh no way he's gotta
wear pants right he's gotta wear pants
I'm feeling good about this I'm not
feeling good about this green and purple
she's like oh she is queen of those
colors a green woman god I'm having a
hard time oh gosh she's second nice no
[Music]
oh that's right he's got like a like a
puka shell necklace right but he'd stole
it from Moana okay I don't care what you
got it I just I don't care where he just
got a I'm gonna make him shine I'm gonna
make him blush
I still got a color
oh well great Jackie give me a second
hey this is what happens when a
cartoonist goes up against an animator
you animators are so fast so I remember
her being incredibly triangular like the
most defining feature of her and her
silhouette is longhorns
which I hope I got right if I didn't I
will be very Oh bad character designer
her body is the thing I just don't
remember the most I think it's just like
a I think oh he is just cloak yeah like
she's mostly clothed I don't remember
seeing her legs okay he looks like the
planters peanut guy or whatever yeah I
think that's a pretty accurate
description I think I'm just drawing
that person like I don't know if this is
what Jiminy Cricket looks oh that
doesn't look great no I'm just gonna
draw my own original character my own
Brian severs original Jiminy Cricket I'm
already there I've been drawing an
original alien cook it for a while now
you got the right idea man I don't know
what I've been doing I would say that a
cartoonist usually works in static
images where as an animator would work
in moving images do you think that's
appropriate to say yeah okay sure are
you just humoring me a little bit okay
you know what this looks like Jiminy
Cricket I'm gonna go the extra mile
start giving him some like shading this
lady she says I hate no she's the bad
lady and she's hard to drive she is
incredibly hard to do the one thing I
remember she has like these green things
these like weird ring is our Lauren
what's the name of the alien from the
Flintstones kazoo is this so weird how
you can have like such a vivid idea of
what a character it looks like in your
head and then you got a draw but then
once it's actually cut push comes to
shove to like recreate it it's like you
just can't yeah that's how you're going
on right now I think this is gonna get
I'm missing plenty I'm missing so much
does it yeah I like I think it's like
perfect and if anyone has critiques for
me don't tell me them all right I'm done
all right I want to be confident I think
I got like the feel of her down but I am
not sure about that stuff I think that I
have drawn Queen Amidala from Star Wars
but just green like she's real sick yeah
his hook is a lot bigger than I thought
it would wait that's his hook
yeah he's got a lot of tattoos yeah
that's why I didn't really like a lot of
tattoos I knew that and I just didn't
want to do it yeah that's my all so I
drew him a bald spot wow he's got a full
head half no I forgot her collar this is
not this thing that I have done at oh my
god okay I knew that I was really
thinking about the Queen from Snow White
mine looks like a like Party City
Halloween store costume okay yeah that's
you know what sort of yeah I got the
color counter kind of good oh he's got
an umbrella umbrella nah he's got a
little spat fun he does look like Joe
Camel a little bit though the top hats
bigger it's like more of a Mad Hatter
top hat yes also he's wearing like a
little blazer you know what I'm not like
a shame though like I got the nose I
think the eye shape was kind of good
yeah he did it all right I don't think I
did all right but I think I did close I
did his best it's like without watching
this movie in like 20 years
oh great both thought that her crow
horns were sort of stripy which they are
yeah they are a little bit strike oh
nice trophy yours looks a lot like a
villain from the Powerpuff Girls or
something you've got like a fan of the
Powerpuff Girls who think it's oh you
did great
I told you I gave him a bald spot
because I thought for some reason he had
a bald spot
listen if I were casting it I would have
Danny DeVito play yeah everything right
yeah if the laps are up my talent are at
the beginner this is a pretty good
picture oh my god is the thing okay so
it's not a bad picture it's just like
it's not at all like what I was
expecting
you got his face better than me I think
I think I had to get his face you did
get his face and his hat I think you got
his energy more like there's a lot of
character and yours it's good I'm just
the bald spot really it really is a hot
spot like you I haven't seen the movie
Jackie yeah you know what I drew him
older I do like retirement age the later
years yeah yeah yeah a lot of -
retirement that's fast food early
retirement Boogaloo
[Music]
[Music]